as more nevadans do get vaccinated for
the coronavirus testing numbers
have dropped dramatically but health
officials still need to track the cases
and the pandemic spread and that's why
they set up a pop-up test site today at
allegion stadium
hector mejia is live there right now to
show us if people are taking advantage
of that hector
well hey there john we're told about 200
people registered ahead of time but this
is operating as a first
come first served basis and we've seen
cars coming and going pretty much all
day here right now
just about less than half a dozen cars
in line the operations happening
outdoors on the parking lot until one
o'clock in the afternoon
there is a big emphasis right now for
testing especially coming out of spring
break and easter gatherings this one day
event was a partnership between
allegiant stadium
the raiders clark county and the
southern nevada health district
they brought enough for 1200 coronavirus
tests
with guidelines changing so much you
might be wondering okay so who should
even get a test
it's for symptomatic and asymptomatic
people also if you traveled without
being fully vaccinated the cdc
recommends to get tested
and self-quarantined for seven days
only fully vaccinated domestic travelers
that's two weeks after your last
required dose
are no longer required to get tested or
to self-quarantine
that's under the new cdc guidelines
however the health district says it
would not be a bad idea to get tested
anyway
that's if you had close contact with
someone who has coveted
or if you were in high risk crowded
areas clark county commissioner michael
naft says it's
the only way to track the virus
we understand everybody's been anxious
to get away but now that you've come
back now the kids are going back to
school and parents are going back to
work
don't be shy about getting tested we
want to make sure that we're not letting
up and not giving an inch for the virus
to continue to spread
right now the health district said there
are no immediate plans to use allegiant
stadium as a future site for the vaccine
distribution
we'll let you know if that changes and
if you can't make it today by one
o'clock this afternoon
not too far from here nearby at unlv
they're also
offering a free coronavirus testing
every day of the week actually from 8
o'clock in the morning
until four in the afternoon reporting
live from malign stadium hector mejia
8 news now